you had a nasty accident you yes yeah
hoverboard yes you were on a hoverboard
and you were playing around with the
hoverboard and good and no it wasn't
good and the result went viral and it
looks like you really got hurt here but
in the long time ago y-you still show
it's fun
[Music]
let's see that again in slow motion
[Applause]
that looks like it really hurt I mean
you're used to pain but that looks
painful
well of course my fool that fell but you
never see because my wife panicked so so
that so she probably dropped the camera
but I hit my head boom I came back up
quick cuz I don't want people to see I
was hurt there's only three people in
the house I jumped up I wish I did end
up with no when I walk to the table and
I sat down I said this is not gonna be
good guys I'm not good so around three
around 3:30 in the morning I went to the
emergency room and after around nine
people in the emergency room they fell
off their little boards - oh no it was a
muckle time so you're waiting shut this
is she the one that put it online yeah
she said people you have to see how
stupid you are
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]